[Music]
you know I wanted to write about what it
means as some people seemingly have to
earn or have to do something to deserve
access to things that we think about is
basic necessity so how hard can you work
to earn access to a meal every night or
like earn or what you have to do to
deserve a good education what do you
have to do to deserve to have housing
and that's one of the ways that race
sort of works in this country so there's
some people that are deemed inherently
worthy so we think about the way
whiteness works and white supremacy
people just deemed white people just
deem worthy of things but there's this
notion that you need to work extra hard
to deserve a great public education I am
from Baltimore and we think about the
school system in Baltimore City is not
funded equitably at all and I go what do
those kids have to do to like earn
equitable funding they actually don't
need to do anything besides just be
alive and one of the things that we need
to do is make sure that we set up a
system where people just have the basic
necessities like food water education we
can guarantee that there's no reason why
we don't have it yeah so actually think
about the difference in equality and
equity right the quality is everybody
gets the same thing equity is that
people get what they need and deserve
and in the work of justice we're almost
always fighting for equity so we think
about things like school funding we are
not asking for equal funding we know
that it just costs more to educate kids
who grew up in poverty it costs more to
educate kids with special needs and we
know that we need to pay that cost that
those kids deserve that we're not saying
that every kid it costs the same to
educate every kid that's just not true
we want a world of equity where people
get what they need and deserve we know
the disparities around criminal justice
that there are disparities around race
and we want an equitable system that
doesn't penalize people for where they
live how they show up with zip code they
come from so the difference between
equity and equality is an important
distinction and the only way to get to
equality calling it access whatever a
metric of equality you want is by having
equity of resources right equity of
experience is a that the equity piece
says that you need something different
and you deserve something different and
from a system level I'm gonna make sure
that you have access to that so I was
talking to somebody about about who Sam
Swanson and she was like people should
have to work for food stamps because if
they work for it they'll have dignity
and I'm like you know not eating I think
is pretty undignified like not having
food
is a lack of dignity right there right
there like food is one of those basic
things we have enough food that we can
feed everybody we have enough water that
everybody can you know have a meal and
three meals every single day like we can
guarantee those things we don't need to
artificially create this requirement
that people like work so they can earn
food that we can actually guarantee
these basic things for people in one of
the things that we have to do as we
fight for social justice is talk about
these things as basic as they are that
it's not radical to believe that we can
live in where the police don't kill
people it's not radical to say that
every kid should be able to read and
write it's not radical or extreme to say
that we can feed every single person
every single day that the only radical
thing about is that we have to say in
the first place like that is actually
where the radical part comes in and we I
think about that because polarization
thrives in a world of extremes and so
often people want to paint our positions
as extreme it's not an extreme position
to say like that there should be equity
of fairness that's not extreme the only
extreme thing about it is that we don't
have it right now that we have to fight
for it I was in a meeting once and we
were talking about welfare and it was
people from the right in the left and
one of her stood up there was a person
who was sort of against welfare and her
push was like you know people need to
people need to like earn it people need
to like work hard for it and if they
work hard for it they'll feel better and
saying I don't know I think that people
like have already worked hard to like
get a meal like they I think that people
being alive is like enough of that and
there's some people who feel like they
just deserve everything but like one of
the ways that white supremacy works is
that people really do feel like they've
already earned they put in the hard work
they've done something or that all the
all the things that they get are
actually the benefits of their hard work
you think about the way wealth works in
this country is that in 20:53 the median
wealth for black people is gonna be $0
the lowest recorded wealth since you've
been recording wealth in this way and
you think about a median wealth of $0
and you think about white wealth which
is will be around a hundred thousand
dollars and the median black walls will
be zero is that it's not like white
people like worked hard for that it's
not like white people like every white
person was like some entrepreneur that
like did all these wealth building
things the government literally gave
white people wealth the government gave
white people housing loans for very
little with very little
the government gave white people land
the highway administration created our
the suburbs and you think about what it
means that the government gave people
I gave white people like education in
maths like those things contributed to
white wealth but their people were like
I worked really hard and it's like how
hard did you work for a system that just
like benefits your skin colour at every
turn the way you didn't do that you know
how hard did you work for every band-aid
to look like you how hard did you work
for nude to be the color of your skin
and not mine like you didn't do that a
system did that and like that you
benefit from the system and part of the
work in white people's to understand the
privilege of whiteness and to understand
how a system provided that and worked to
dismantle it it actually is dangerous of
teachers so there's a study that came
out that for the first time measures how
meritocracy impacts middle schoolers and
it's like a seventh grade at seventh
grade kids and it shows that kids
actually kids of color do worse later if
they believe that meritocracy is like a
real thing because the system starts to
bear down on them in hard ways they
think that it's a result of like them
just not working hard and it's like no
we know that the way systemic racism
shows up later like means that no matter
how gifted you are how great you are
the outcome still just aren't the same
we know what's criminal justice you
think about New York City that 90% of
the people arrested for marijuana are
black and brown you and I both know that
the 90% of people in New York City
smoking weed are not black or brown when
we think about the arrests we think
about the sweeties in education the
meritocracy sometimes causes people to
blame themselves for outcomes and not
realizing the system is almost
guaranteeing a set of outcomes
[Music]